at least one man was believed to have
been in this house when he was hit by an
intercepted Russian missile
he was rushed to hospital
Emergency Services search for anybody
else Dead or Alive under the rubble
a mother and daughter were also found
injured in the house next door
tetsiana cries into her friend's arms
and said that has been explored illusion
and that my daughter was unconscious and
desirable she is in a hospital now I
don't know her condition
Tatiana's other daughter Jana arrives
mama stop now please she says stop
crying
salvage food from the fridge sits on a
wall
Jana looks her way through the
destruction
my grandmother made this she says
my sister is in hospital I don't know
what the latest is my niece was also
injured by shrapnel
residents climb over the rubble to
inspect the damage and check that
friends and neighbors are safe
this mobile phone footage reportedly
shows one of dozens of Russian cruise
missiles soaring across the sky
and this footage shows what's believed
to be a Ukrainian air defense team
successfully destroying another before
it reached its Target
the authorities say the majority of
missile Isles in this latest barrage
were intercepted but the sheer level of
Destruction in this residential area of
Kiev and the fear amongst people living
here shows how even a successful
interception can destroy people's lives
anxious faces hundreds of kilometers
from the Eastern and Southern front
lines
around 9am there was a huge explosion
and the shock wave through my grandson
from his bed were afraid because this is
the second missile that was intercepted
in this area but this one seems to have
exploded
the missiles have been flying over this
area since the invasion in February we
hide in my brother's basement 35 people
shelter there
a blanket covers a dead dog killed in
the blast
the Jonah finds her pet alive she
cradles it in her arms amongst what
remains of her home
don't be afraid she says don't be afraid
Charles Stratford Al Jazeera